what is the state of the European Union
after a year which featured terrorist
attacks waves of migrants breaks it and
rising nationalism it depends on who you
talk to of course but to jean-claude
Juncker European Commission President
making his state of the EU addressed MEP
s who is a clutch of threats social
justice unemployment and populism among
them about soft and stainless in Grisha
all soft and state the Queen fragment
even docked to an strengthen young for
Milton Vera this F net tingle appeared
in fabulous was former in them as can be
done and are given come populist moose
loose chemically in Gig entire populace
was half problem which led him to the
British multi lives in you the respect
Iran couldn't the darwin sugilite the
British anxiety over the oil patient on
each D understand anishka favors the
other and four valences pretty sure all
streets Gazoo misspelled arising but he
had this morning so these are no longer
heard the snow their unique when anguish
and sugan Sabina mocked haven't come
testify to escape Arizona abandom of
afflicted field as we can be mocked
Ellicott gaben begun mr. Juncker
promised to boost the European
Investment Fund
supporting job-creating projects of SMEs
and big players to 500 billion euros by
2020 and he urged closer military
integration live up the permit to the
upon the last shell whistles the
capacity military the police individual
duty was on song plant Masha the
protects no delay much of it was well
received by any PS the European Way of
life steep UTC a landmark to achieved
English fear esto en fait la Furman
from this being out from minor fraction
and absolutely astonishing shock loading
Coeur de - Shaniqua commissar in that we
had of the internet continuities we are
I can internet concerning some fee an
anti pedestrian
in tanki tough you know a be empirical
invisible a quasi impalpable a super
ecologic amapá aura per vendor labora
hakurei in the region's a political
determinate seon-young ran the core
arrow pale not so for the British leader
of the ECR today was billed as a
relaunch
but sadly is fundamentally the same
mantra we've heard year after year more
military integration more requests for
money
from member states more debt for
tomorrow's children to cake to keep
today's socialists happy this answer
from the Liberals our duty our
responsibility is to make from brexit a
success for Europe we need European
solutions and European capacities the
fastest as possible Europe is also the
Cure against the cancer of nationalism
that we have today the soil pH of house
must be de ba boom ba vehicle it's
mostly dimension of all barbarity bagon
burgum it pattaya and Wornall midsection
drop smith Niharika and victim etc
invade Alaska at Susanna and a plea from
the Greens for unity to leaders
gathering this week in Slovakia to
brainstorm a future without Britain
Felix Mellon owns a myth Indians
Fischetti Muslim from the far right
there were warnings of trouble head is
clear there are no lessons that are
going to be learned from brexit indeed
it was the usual recipe more Europe and
in this particular case of course more
military Europe a European army a common
defense and it isn't going to change the
rapid growth in opposition passes across
the whole of Europe
effects exist abolition taboo Lee
Brittany luckily possibly the shock
children in European mu dou Satya aloha
montage the provision catastrophe
sternly take her massage the next week
so crucial there's the post brexit
summit in bratislava on Friday then
European heads of government meet later
in the month